hey crazies we've all played with
magnets before right the way they
attract each other seems like magic
but it isn't it's science there's just a
magnetic force pulling them together one
magnet can reach out over space and pull
or push on another magnet but what if I
told you magnetic force does not exist
you might react with skepticism no no no
or anger that's it you've crossed a line
or confusion huh or maybe even sheer
madness ah come to think of it that's a
brilliant name for a hair salon haircut
clone you should call it sheer madness
that's brilliant
but if you're a little curious you might
ask how do we know what's real and what
isn't we've seen this issue before with
centrifugal force Coriolis force and
most recently gravity none of those
forces exist either a force is only real
if it exists from every point of view if
it only exists from some points of view
it's a fictitious force so all we need
to prove a force isn't real is to find
one point of view where it doesn't exist
let's take a look at magnetism these
magnets work because each of its iron
atoms has four unpaired electrons who
spins line up with each other one iron
atom affects the others around it
forming magnetic domains as long as
those domains aren't random you've got
yourself a magnet electric current in
wires can also exert magnetic force
because magnetism is created whenever
charges move and in that lies the
problem
magnetic force depends on motion and
motion is relative an electric current
is just a bunch of electrons in a wire
moving from one positive nucleus to the
next this wire can't exert any electric
forces because it's neutral there is no
electric field
however the moving electrons do create a
magnetic field so they can exert
magnetic force on other moving charges
like this proton keeping pace with them
well I mean it could be anything
positive a squirrel a hockey puck Milton
a rubber ducky but for simplicity we'll
stick with the proton it experiences a
force away from the wire no problems yet
but let's change the point of view what
if you're moving along with the proton
it won't appear to be moving at all and
neither will the electrons but now the
nuclei are moving the other direction
yes they're creating a magnetic field
but they can't exert a magnetic force on
the proton because it isn't moving it's
confirmed
magnetic force does not exist yet the
proton still moves away so what gives it
turns out we can't make sense of this
without considering special relativity
particularly length contraction the
faster things go the shorter they are
usually this isn't something we have to
worry about unless we're going fast but
sometimes it's necessary even at slow
speeds
if those nuclei are moving they must
contract along the direction of motion
but charge is invariant meaning every
one measures it the same so the
contraction changes their charge density
meaning any spot of the wire has more
positive charge than negative the wire
is no longer neutral so electric force
pushes away the proton weight that
electric force didn't exist from the
other point of view it doesn't exist
either ah
the thing is though no matter how we
look at this wire scenario there's
always an electric force or a magnetic
force or some combination of the two
they're really just two manifestations
are the same thing we call that
electromagnetic force but representing
it mathematically requires tensors which
can be a bit tricky so we usually just
pretend like they're separate things
thanks for liking and sharing this video
and a special thanks to our patrons on
patreon who have been a huge help please
subscribe if you'd like to see more and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy